oh very good as a Korean is it hard like
stare at their eyebrows and not want to
wax them is that hard
do some waxing yes I don't really see
that yeah because we are you white
actually the Royal Tenenbaums over here
I can't sorry about that what are you
selling ice cream okay
what's the scarf what's that all about
today that's new Western Star yeah do
you believe that women have [ __ ] him
yeah women [ __ ] a lot of garbage on
the fence I've been talking a lot about
I [ __ ] ugly all the time since high
school
yeah ever discriminated there's
something about feeling completely okay
when we like we like to give charity to
see how are you like oh you want right
off on your taxes yeah Terri feel most
uninhibited when they're ugly yeah I
feel like I can be my most disgusting
self when they when I know that this is
the best they are you're really alive
with him my little Eskimo emoji oh those
are assassin eyes right there listen
today now get it up like like when did
you realize you were hot um my girl you
guys but is there a moment you're like
oh wow I'm uh I'm a hot person I'm a
attracted you probably didn't think I
was cute until I was 19 but I was
already very sexual previous but I never
got with like hot guys but when I was
younger
that's just what dudes would like low
self-esteem I was eight I would just
have sex with all the younger with
ugly virgins really and I really enjoyed
it did you take a lot of you you take a
lot of virgins mm-hmm that was my thing
that was like you were the virgin
stalker and they were all just like
nerdy kind of like very insecure boys
you're like every pornos dream right
isn't that like superhot chicks [ __ ]
but I wasn't people then I was just a
little hotter than them I just didn't
know how to you know I wasn't very girly
then when I hear girls say that I don't
believe but I don't see why you would
lie I came from the Philippines so my
accent was really sick I didn't know
that I had to shave my legs I had a bowl
cut you know things are happening for me
yet really yes I don't know why I can't
believe this I'm not not you never lie I
do you have no really started getting
cute when I realize okay grow your hair
out kalila shave your legs whack you
know just yeah wax the mustache don't
look so you know you know when I first
when I met her on tinder right so I go
out to Long Beach I thought she was
pretty but when I when I first saw her
naked well I looked up up to God yeah
it's a combination of the elephant has a
beer yeah that's true as a carpenter
yeah but maybe like you know Japanese
cloth so my point is is there so I
looked up in the sky and I went you know
when you go have you ever been with a
chick so hot yeah well you look up and
you go thank you yes
yeah it's a gift yes that's how I
thought when I first you know that's so
nice
that's really nice four years later or
now look I got him out I paid for that
no for that is there I was there he was
there to help me over there what is the
point of having [ __ ] you money Bobby if
he can't buy your girlfriend a nice
first started dating did you feel the
pressure to get big girl he begged me
not to get them oh why is he he's into
the cream boys yeah
No well you know what happened she got
the man and all her health issues
happened oh yeah it's been a nightmare
you know so just generally is this a
comedy podcast yeah it is but we could
take a long okay reel okay yeah dude
it's not all like you know me switches
and all these [ __ ] I mean reverse
each other
[Music]